- Your friend Ashton Kutcher
became literally my
marker to all my friends.
I was like, "If any of you ever
put me on that show Punk'D,
"I will never speak to you again."
Because it is, you know
what I hate in life?
As much as I'm like a scrappy cat,
I do not like gotcha moments.
Don't let me work my entire
life to be a good person
and then nail me in a corner
by poking me like an
animal and then going,
"Oh, that's who she really is.
"We knew, we knew it, it's fake.
"She's not a good person, she's a jerk."
But I do love Ashton
Kutcher, nothing against him.
But boy, that show really scared me.
- When then your gonna hate
this. Ashton, come on out!
(Drew laughing)
No, I'm just kidding.
- Okay, there is a "That
'90s Show" revival.
- There is, yeah.
(audience cheering)
It's starring Deborah Jo
Rupp who played my mom
and Kurtwood Smith,
and they're great friends
of mine and amazing people,
and a whole new group of kids, yeah.
- Okay, tell me about the
show that you are in now.
Second season, big hit,
really respected, great reviews.
"Home Economics."
- I love it. It's-
(audience clapping)
This cast is,
yeah, I really feel like I was
part of a dream team before
and I was so nervous because of COVID.
I'd met all of them
but I hadn't been in the same
room with all of us together.
It's like dating or something.
At first you go,
you can't predict it,
you don't know until you show up.
And the first day I went
to work I was so nervous.
And then about two days in,
I was driving home and I
was just straight up cocky.
They're so great.
I was like, "I don't even
have to do anything."
They're just my favorite group of people.
- Well, there is another television show
that I heard you are a fan of.
- Okay, yeah. I mean, yeah.
Look, I'm into "The Bachelor," okay.
I wasn't originally.
I started dating a girl,
she became my wife,
and she pushed it on me.
And then a couple years
into it I started to realize
when I was out of town I was like
"Well, you're not gonna
watch it tonight, right?
"Can you like, wait until,"
which, by the way, I
missed "Women Tell All."
- Okay, what are you
thinking prediction-wise
that's gonna happen,
'cause we're almost at
the end of the season.
- I know, without
watching "Women Tell All"
I'm hesitant to make any firm predictions.
- Well, there is someone actually here
that we have as a surprise for you
who I think can fill in some blanks.
- Who?
- Oh, it's just the host
of the show, Jesse Palmer.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- How are you (indistinct)?
I know.
I'm not Ashton Kutcher.
- [Topher] She just said
she hates gotcha moments.
- But this is a good one!
- I'll squeeze on in.
- We're not gonna tease you.
- That's why when Tom Cruise-
- No, this is an amazing surprise.
It's great to meet you, man.
- Listen, just like your childhood,
I was drinking in a parking garage
down the street here in New York,
and I heard that you were
this big fan of the show.
So on behalf of the Bachelor Nation,
I just wanted to to stop by and say
thank you, man, appreciate it.
- You gotta do me a favor.
You gotta look into the camera
and say hello to my wife.
I'll get so many brownie points.
Say "Hello, Ashley Grace."
She's so jealous right, go ahead.
- Ashley Grace,
will you accept Topher's final rose?
(audience cheering)
- I also wanna say hi to my friend Wendy
because we were just talking about
all of the bachelor fantasies right now
and I'm sending her videos going,
"Wendy, you're not gonna believe
"what's happening right now."
(upbeat music)